welcome back to the lobby we're here to
talk a bad bidness Justin hey Walt how
you doing I'm all about the business has
business business business is good i'm
wearing a tie today you are what's it
what's on your tie it's I got this from
Studio Ghibli it's a holder wrote I nice
nothing says Rosana nothing says
business like some sweet is it jibley or
Ghibli Jane Titan like the actual
pronunciation ya jus booty like I need
say that I'm asking the man who speaks
Japanese fluently just Gillie give it a
jiggling David q booty we're not here to
talk about studio Jubilee we're here to
talk about activision purchasing came
calm calm calm they bought Kim calm Kim
Kardashian's amazing website came back
up she does have a very successful
mobile game that but not as successful
as the guy who made megaupload as I was
mega comp claim and now Activision own
Kim comics guess so well no no not not
Kim this is king taco King calm rise
king the guys make candy crush yes and
other games that you know really well
like I d crush soda saga okay which
candy saga and owners of the words candy
and saga as the people who made the
banner saga are all too aware of it
those so those were those were I think
settled out of court okay the the actual
details of those will never come to
light they also we're trying to go after
somebody who who was using the word
candy in a title so easy Raiders they
went after the developer of candy swipe
which came out before candy crush saga
is called candy swipe can't ice white
wow did they did they try and take
Halloween to course no no there's no
halloween in the title no but candy but
they go after comic book characters for
using the word crush hey Siri no no no
that's not look at it so true I can't
tell who knows but let's talk about what
we do know activision's purchased this a
company for an incredible amount of
money how much money and why do they do
it so it's over six billion dollars
because which is an insane amount of
money and I think the reason that we
think about is it like no matter what
all these amounts of money for these
companies are crazy but this one sounds
especially huge because recently disney
bought Star War
for four billion dollars yeah that means
this is worth more to Activision than
Star Wars is to dis- who cares about
this this guy he wishes he is playing
candy crush this guy yes like a man I
gotta kill the Jedi cuz they bet me in
candy crush and it's such like not only
a film franchise with Star Wars but
merchandising there's so many ways are
gonna make money from that yeah the
amount of money is is at the end of the
day really not that big of a thing
because candy crush even now when it's
on a decline candy crush and King are
not doing that great they still make
over a billion dollars a year there it
so you know Activision is gonna make
this back very quickly so it's it's not
really the matter of money but the fact
that they value it at that amount of
money that and publisher like Activision
who has so many properties who has so
much that they can do they could buy
hundreds of smaller developers but
instead they went after the very biggest
yeah you will and what do you think the
reason is that they did that so is it
like either it's because they're trying
to you know get a foothold into this
massive not emerging market mobile games
emerging anymore it's so someday the
global games on it's very much like amar
it's bigger than the mainstream games in
terms of gross revenue surely at this
stage in just in terms of people who
play it like people who don't think of
themselves as gamers more actually
gamers yeah and they spend more time and
more money on them than most of us do
like it when you think about Zynga when
they think about a weight like we think
of a whale as I go this person spent a
hundred or two hundred dollars in micro
transactions it Zynga a whale as someone
who could spend thousands of dollars a
month on farmville yeah what what are
you buying and if your span it's like
any other game that we play if you're
spend enough time on it then you're
willing to buy the next DLC or whatever
I'm not going to spend a thousand
dollars on file no matter how good
fallout 4 might be I'm not going to
spend a thousand dollars a month on it
so let's talk about I guess the one of
the business reasons for this because
Kings shares have jumped up something
like fourteen percent activision's have
also had a spike today like how much of
this is just posturing for shareholders
how much is this is to do with sort of
how business is perceived and not really
like inroads into like new markets are
they going to start making call of duty
games on phones like what what are we
looking at here I think those are the
kinds of things that we're going to see
from our perspective this seems like a
ridiculous thing it sounds like active
the call of duty maker is buying candy
crush saga and they're not because candy
crush is just a small thing and that
will ultimately be gone and King knows
that King knows that they have kind of a
one-trick pony they've tried other games
yeah and like Rovio like a the farmville
developer zynga those games have all
failed nobody cares about those games as
much anymore they've tried to diversify
and they've just been completely
unsuccessful and King knows that they
need other properties they need a way to
distribute games that that will reach a
bigger audience because they're on a
downward trend in Activision on the
other side has so many huge titles like
Call of Duty on the pc side they have
blizzard they have World of Warcraft
birthstone they have these really these
games that capture the core but they
don't have a casual audience and that's
where EA has just been killing them in
the past couple of years that EA as much
as we might disparage some of the things
they do they're really successful
especially with their mobile games with
a lot of people to play Simpsons topic
and this is activision's opportunity to
get a foot in that market without having
to start from the bottom like they're
basically taking not the game this is
the top anymore because that's the clash
of clans type games yeah age of whatever
age age of war Morgan Georgia current
top game of age but even now years after
its come out candy crush saga is still
like number three and one of the others
is number six and this is a way for them
to get a lot of people really quickly
they have access now to a huge swath of
users and a lot of money then they
weren't getting before from that market
which is kind of a like I know people
always throw at that term but a blue
ocean yeah like it is endless people who
don't think of themselves as gamers play
these games your mom is someone who
won't I don't know about your mom like
we never talked about that one yeah
we're doing oh yeah you know about my
mom but we don't talk about it but my
mom and particularly loves these kind of
dumb games and she wouldn't like you I
wouldn't think of her as a hardcore
gamer but you'll spend hours just like
which is the problem games of Hajj in
perpetuity because the different it's a
controller with all these buttons at the
closest you know hard you know
traditional game core game whatever we
refer to ourselves as got to the
mainstream was the we and the only
reason for that was because it was a
remote control because people knew how
to use remote control grandmother knew
Eddie use her own motor controller so
she could play tennis
and like I think that we're in a really
insular bubble we be ps4 and Xbox what
are doing really well they're doing
better than the 316 the ps3 or pc is
doing incredibly well as well I getting
more audience it seems like but when you
think of that in the broader context
like yeah it's doing better than the
previous consoles didn't it's still it's
gaining acceptance and it's making a lot
of money but not compared to something
like mobile gaming not compared to
something like the ubiquity of TV
reaching out to literally the entire
world because we like we love call duty
and fallout and all of these other
really big franchises I can't wait to
play star wars battlefront but at the
end of the day that's actually a really
small percentage of the potential
audience of something that like oh I'm
just going to match these three colors I
can you can release that in any country
there's no yeah no need to translation
yeah there is localization there is
translate not to despair it not to put
anything like that but you want to do a
lot easier child you can't read and it
can still figure it out they're gonna
figure out how and put those together I
want so should we be worried like the
those of us who were in this bubble
those of us who were watching this show
and play these games that are behind us
and are excited about for and stuff like
you look at a company like Kaname who is
basically just said see the you know
traditional video game industry because
if there are massive money they have in
their casinos pachinko parlors there's a
company like Activision which obviously
still has massive fingers in Harley no
traditional games especially with
blizzard and they own some of the
biggest franchises but they're also like
a far ways away from the people who make
chrome premium pitfall like now they're
getting into this market which might be
that much more you know revenue driving
for them so like is this something we
need to be continuously worried about
because we're seeing so many companies
which were near and dear to video games
the bigger ones at least spending more
time on this okay when you say worry
about it like are we is this going to
change what these big companies do and
how they make money yeah I'm sure like
from that perspective it's not going to
be great there might be a new metal gear
game which is going to be a pachinko
parlor like this might be the
continuation of Metal Gear Solid in that
sense yeah we're gonna lose these
established franchises that we might
have a lot of nostalgia for a lot of
something that's its holding on to it at
the same time all most of these
companies are not getting out of triple
a gaming they still see this as your a
valuable audio
and we want to create games for you it's
really expensive to make things like
star wars battlefront and these huge
multi-year multi-million dollar there's
a reason we don't cheat GTA every year
it's expensive and it takes a lot of
time and and people and money but they
star still making those and those in the
long run still pay off but at the same
time we still have great indie
developers who are making really
wonderful experiences with really small
teams and that's the kind of thing
that's never going to go away and that's
the kind of way that we're gonna I think
continue to get the experiences that we
love and that'll be really memorable for
us from a gameplay perspective and not
having to worry as much about how can we
increase our revenue this quarter over
what it was a previous quarter
interesting times Justin hey well thank
you for coming on and explaining that
crazy madness to me and everyone
watching king com now owned by the good
people at Activision let us know what
you think do you play candy crush do you
want none of your call of duty on phones
let us know in the comment box below